so let's start off with the absolute
Basics again this is europython I don't
expect any of you to have any knowledge
of what audio is hopefully you know what
python is let's answer this first
question of what is audio what do I mean
when I say audio well if you ask the
dictionary it'll tell you audio is sound
especially when recorded transmitted or
reproduced but that's still kind of
vague what is sound how does sound work
at a really basic level well sound is
really just any vibration any sort of
vibration through the air that isn't too
slow or too fast for our ears to pick up
our ears are sensitive to a range of
different vibration speeds between about
10 vibrations per second all the way
through to 20 000 vibrations per second
which sounds like a lot uh but it's not
that much in this range there's a whole
bunch of different sounds that you've
definitely heard before in fact
everything you've heard is within this
range towards the lower end of the range
you'll have sounds like bass guitars and
rumbles and car engines and things like
that and those have fewer vibrations per
second
in the middle of the range you'll have
sounds like the human voice and kind of
higher pitched sounds maybe musical
instruments a lot of stuff like that and
towards the top of the range you have
sounds like birds chirping and other
kind of high-pitched sounds so higher
pitches mean higher vibrations per
second or technically higher frequencies
uh these frequencies here are noted in
the unit called Hertz often notated as
HZ and they're called Hertz because
higher frequencies hurts your ears no
it's actually named after this guy uh
this German physicist Heinrich Rudolph
Hertz
but nonetheless that's how sound kind of
works at a basic level
so if that's how Sound Works in the real
world how does digital audio work how do
we get that into a computer measure it
and play with it in our code well just
like everything else in a computer we
need to measure it in the real world to
get it into a computer and start working
with it so let's do some of that
measurement here let's measure this by
putting a graph on the screen and of
course we're going to need to put some
axes on this graph so we'll put time on
the bottom and then something called
amplitude on the y-axis here on the left
hand side
now amplitude I'm not going to get too
much into what this means but you can
think of this as the position of the
sound wave or how if the sound wave is
pushing towards you or pulling away from
you that's the amplitude and we'll we'll
see that on the screen in a second here
so I'm going to play a sound and I
really hope this works and as you hear
the sound you'll see some points show up
on the screen and that'll be me clicking
a button on my laptop and recording the
value of the speaker or the microphone
here at each point so let's try this
foreign
[Music]
Okay so we've got a bunch of points on
the screen here there's not too many of
them they're not very detailed you might
say but we've recorded the position of
the microphone that was used to record
this audio at various points in time
I was pushing the button roughly once
every 0.4 seconds or so and if we take
the inverse of that or the reciprocal of
that we get a value in hertz again that
unit for frequency and that value of 2.5
Hertz here is what we call our sample
rate this is how often we sample the
microphone and actually figure out where
the microphone is at that point in time
now there's other things we can look at
here you notice that this graph is a
little bit odd it's got points at the
top and the bottom and that's because
silence is not at the bottom of the
graph it's actually in the middle and
the top and bottom of the graph here are
can very confusingly both maximum
loudness we have maximum loudness in the
positive direction at the top and in the
negative Direction at the bottom and
again this is because sound is a wave
sound is vibration and it goes back and
forth so if it goes back and forth a
very small amount it's going to stay
towards the middle of the graph and if
it goes back and forth a lot it's going
to hit the extremes so maximum loudness
again is the top and the bottom of the
graph very strangely
and then we can measure each point here
so we've got this point on the left
which might have 60 amplitude so we
could represent that as 0.6 in code and
we've got this point here which might be
90 amplitude but in the opposite
direction so we'll look at that as
negative 0.90 so with this we kind of
have enough points to try to reconstruct
what that sound was and reconstruct the
entire waveform
but unfortunately we really don't have
enough detail here I didn't push the
button often enough for me to get enough
information to reproduce what we just
heard and to play it back essentially so
now instead of 2.5 Hertz let's re-record
this again at a much higher sample rate
and you're going to see a lot more data
on the screen here so let's get rid of
that and try this again foreign
[Music]
okay so there's more points there now
there's a lot more points in fact you
can't even see the individual points we
sampled at 44 100 points per second or
44 1000 Hertz and that's just a huge
amount of data there so we can't do much
with what we're seeing right now we're
going to have to zoom in to actually see
what's on the inside here so let's do
that let's Zoom all the way in from the
second scale down to the millisecond
scale here and as we get closer and
closer you can actually see the
individual sound waves that were used or
that came out of that saxophone and went
into your ears and this is what your
ears were vibrating like back and forth
in this pattern
now here if we measure the distance
between these two peaks not these points
but these two peaks here we can actually
see there's a duration in there in
milliseconds that's 5.7 milliseconds
between Peaks and if we do a little bit
of math on that again do one cycle
divided by that we can find out even the
frequency of the note that the saxophone
was playing so just from measuring that
uh that waveform over and over we're
able to find out the note and I think
that's actually an F so that we can find
out what musical note was being played
there just by doing some math but let's
keep going even deeper we're still only
looking at the milliseconds level let's
go from milliseconds down to
microseconds where we'll be able to see
the actual samples so now that we're
super zoomed in the actual samples look
like little points along this graph and
we can measure again every single point
at the microseconds level and this gives
us a representation of the audio
and here's the real secret that I want
to tell you all today this is digital
audio this is all it is digital audio is
really just streams of numbers
nothing too complicated although you
can't do complicated things with it this
is how you represent digital audio
so if this is how digital audio Works
let's take a look at how we might store
this in different ways let's zoom out a
little bit again here
so what we're looking at here is called
uncompressed floating Point data it's
32-bit or 64-bit floats and this is
pretty heavy it's about 21 megabytes per
minute of audio that's a lot of data if
we had to store all that for every
single song that you listen to that
would be well really expensive it would
take a long time to download and so on
so people store audio in different ways
sometimes we can store audio as
uncompressed fixed Point data as 16-bit
or 24-bit or 32-bit signed integers and
on the lower end of that we get 10
megabytes per minute instead of 21
megabytes per minute but that's still a
lot so back in the 90s people invented
some very very clever compression codecs
these compressed floating Point codecs
like MP3 and OG and so on compress all
the way down to one megabyte per minute
of audio which is much much easier to
deal with however as you can see there
we're no longer actually looking at the
numbers we're not looking at these
floating Point values we're just looking
at encoded bytes so to do anything with
this compressed data we're going to have
to use a library or some other system to
decode it and then use the numeric
information we get after decoding here
so that brings me smoothly to my next
topic here reading and editing audio in
Python so if that's how audio Works in a
computer and that's how we might store
it on disk how do we get that into our
python code well here's where I Shield
just a little bit for the library that
I'm working on for quite a while called
pedalboard and we're going to start here
by actually diving into the code we're
going to start by importing pedalboard
by doing from pedalboard.io import audio
file
now in Python if you want to open up a
regular file you use the open function
but here we're going to use the audio
file Constructor or the audio file let's
call it a function and it's going to do
the exact same thing
so we can do with audio file my favorite
song.ap3 as F and that'll open a context
manager for US Open this file up and
allow us to play with what's inside this
file it'll automatically decompress the
audio for us and just give us data that
we can deal with
so let's look at some properties here we
can do F dot sample rate to give us the
sampling rate that we talked about
earlier
we can do f.num channels to tell us the
number of channels that are in this
audio file oftentimes audio files have
two channels one for the left ear and
one for the right ear
and then we can actually just read the
data out of it we can do F dot read here
and we can ask for three samples just
the first three samples of the file now
pedalboard is going to give us the first
three samples in each channel so we'll
get back an array of a shape or with a
certain shape here the shape here is two
three for two channels left and right
and then three frames of audio here now
if you're not familiar with
multi-dimensional arrays they're not too
complicated you can kind of think of
them as arrays of arrays but in this
case each sub array has a fixed shape so
we can just use that shape parameter to
see what shape the overall array has
but okay if that's how we can open a
file what can we do with the audio once
we pull it out of that file let's give
that a try oops uh just to illustrate
here the Left Channel of the audio is
the first array here and then the right
channel is the second array so we can
actually separate these out very easily
like that
but going back to the start here let's
take a look at opening up another audio
file and instead of just reading in
three frames let's read in all of them
let's do audio equals F dot read F dot
frames now if that frames here is just a
property that tells us how many frames
we have in the entire file and here we
get back an array with a certain shape
again two channels so that's left and
right as the First Dimension and then
1.3 million samples as our second
dimension channels first and then
samples afterwards
so from there we can then look on to
actually decompose this audio a bit we
can do audio at zero to give us the Left
Channel audio one to give us the right
Channel and you can see there are arrays
with totally different contents here so
they don't have to be correlated with
each other
and then using Python's array slicing
syntax we can start to chop up this
audio and edit it trim it as you would
so we can do audio and then pass in an
empty slice for the First Dimension and
then I slice up to the first 100 samples
for the second dimension and that'll
give us a stereo chunk of audio or a
stereo array that contains only the
first 100 samples but 100 samples
doesn't really mean too much for us it
just tells us that's 100 points what
does that mean in terms of seconds or in
terms of duration
well to get that we can do some math
using f.sample rate here so again the
sampling rate we talked about before we
can ask for the first 10 seconds by
using just regular python array syntax
and doing F dot sample rate times 10. we
can also ask for the last 10 seconds
with the exact same array slicing syntax
negative f dot sample rate times 10
there
okay so now we know how to read audio
and kind of play around with it as an
array and slice it up
what can we do with it though we've
really just opened up an audio file how
can we make it maybe sound different or
you know look different something like
that so let's go all the way back up to
the top let's read in our MP3 file again
and this time let's just Whittle it down
to one channel just get the mono audio
or one channel from the Left Channel
here
now let's try to change how this sounds
instead of just playing with a regular
audio file let's add some delay to this
let's add some Echo this is the same
effect that you might have if you're in
a big space and you might hear a
slapback echo of your voice coming back
from the back of a room which is
actually what I'm hearing right now but
let's add that to this audio file with
some code let's see how few lines of
code we can write in Python to make this
happen
so let's set some parameters first let's
set delay seconds equal to 0.2 or
one-fifth of a second so let's make our
audio delayed by 0.2 seconds
and then let's convert that into samples
so that we can deal with this as like
array offsets rather than floating Point
numbers here
and then we also should set another
parameter here which is how loud are
echo or how louder delay is going to be
so let's set that to volume equals 0.75
which is 75 of the original volume
and now we're going to do some math
don't get scared it's actually fairly
simple but we're going to do a little
bit of math here
so we'll iterate through the original
array we'll do 4i in range Len mono so
just iterate through all the samples in
the original array
and then if we have enough room to add
Echo afterwards so if I plus delay
samples is less than the end of our
array then let's add some delay let's do
mono at I plus delay samples plus equals
mono at I times volume so that's a
little confusing to think about but let
me give you a quick visual example to
see what this means
so let's play with a smaller array maybe
something where our delay is only one
sample and let's say our signal looks
like this we have six samples 0.00.1 and
so on what we're essentially doing here
is taking a copy of this array
multiplying it by volume
and then shifting It Forward by the
number of samples we want to delay so
we'll shift it forward like that add the
results together
and then the result is essentially the
original signal plus also a delayed copy
that's a little bit quieter
but I'm still just showing you a bunch
of numbers on the screen and a bunch of
math what if we can hear this and the
great thing about working with audio
code is that you often can hear what you
do what you're doing and what it sounds
like so let's listen to a signal before
and after it's gone through these seven
lines of code
no delay sounds normal sounds like a
little piano and now after going through
this code
[Music]
kind of cool right with only this code
that you see on the screen here we're
able to take the actual audio signal you
just heard and alter it in a way that
our ears can make sense of right we've
done something kind of neat there
but let's not
let's do some even more extreme Effects
by writing some python code
so let's get rid of that and now let's
load up a new file let's load up
something here called coolguitar.wave
which is a cool little guitar sample
again let's read in the audio file with
f dot read we'll read all the frames in
the file and just take the first channel
then let's uh make this guitar sound
sound a little more extreme let's add
some Distortion to it so we'll set some
parameters here like the amount of gain
that we want to add here uh what's the
unit on gain to be honest I actually
don't know here this is just a
multiplier we're going to multiply our
signal by and the higher this number the
more extreme it's going to sound
now we'll also set a amount of volume
that we want to multiply this by so if
we have a gain level of 200 we're going
to knock this down by 90 and take only
10 percent of the original signals
volume because we're going to distort
this it's going to sound pretty loud
and then just like before we're going to
iterate sample by sample over the entire
array here and change the value of each
sample so here instead of doing any sort
of delay or array offsets we're just
going to modify every single sample in
place and say mono at I is equal to
math.10h of mono at I times gain times
volume
now you might be asking what is
math.tamh and that's for a different
talk I'm not going to get into the math
of this but you'll be able to hear this
in just a second
so let's listen to cool guitar dot wave
before our processing
sounds like a guitar now this is going
to be a tiny bit louder as you can kind
of see on the screen there but don't
cover your ears I don't think it should
be too loud
so that sounded a lot more metal a lot
more high energy if you might say and
all we had to do to make that sound is
the code that you see on the screen
there in fact this is even less code
than what we had to do to implement some
DeLay So with very small amounts of code
in Python you can actually alter sounds
and edit sounds like this very easily
okay so I've talked about a couple cool
things you can do here let's talk about
problems you might run into working with
audio and python python is great working
with audio code is great but sometimes
there are some rough edges to make it
really difficult to work with python
code or with audio code in Python
so let's start with uh well a similar
example to what we had before so let's
load up my favorite song.b3 and let's
say we want to do something different
with this file we want to load it up and
make it louder and then save it back to
disk again so we'll do with audio file
here
we'll do audio equals F dot read F dot
frames and then once we've read in the
audio we'll make the entire thing louder
we'll make it louder by multiplying it
by 2 which takes each sample value and
multiplies by two
and we'll save the result back out to
disk again we can use pedalboard for
this by doing with audio file out.mp3
and passing the W flag as the second
parameter and then passing in the sample
rate because we need to know the sample
rate in order to save
and then we just do o.right and like any
other file we've written that to disk
there's a problem here this code will
probably run just fine on your laptop
and it'll run just fine on all the test
MP3s that you have or the small audio
files that you have but what happens if
the input is not something you control
what if that audio file at the top is
not actually a small song or a small MP3
file you have but something that a user
gives to you or something that comes in
from a web service or it's you know
you're running this on a large catalog
of audio
what if that is two hours long
well if that MP3 file is two hours long
you might not really be able to tell
that until your code crashes because
once you read all the frames in that
ends up being 2.3 gigabytes of audio and
this is something kind of deceptive
about audio in general is that because
of audio compression and because how
about how effective audio compression is
you can actually have very small files
that uncompress to massive massive
amounts of audio in memory
so there are very simple techniques we
can use to get around this and one way
to do this is by chunking the audio and
processing it in chunks instead so let's
try that here let's set a chunk size of
500 000 let's open up our input audio
file and let's open up our output audio
file as well so we're kind of nesting
these context managers really just so
they'll fit on the screen I know you can
put them all in one line
and then as long as we have audio to
read in so while F dot tell is less than
F dot frames so as long as there's more
audio coming in
let's read in a single chunk of audio
process just that chunk make it louder
and then save just that chunk to our
output file
and now with this we no longer use two
gigabytes of memory for a two hour long
file we only ever use up to four
megabytes of memory here and this input
file could be two hours long or 20 hours
long or it could be a stream that never
ends and our code is still going to work
because we're processing in chunks
instead
so what I really want you to walk away
with here is not chunking or that exact
line of code that you saw there but that
you should think of audio as a stream
audio is really a stream it's streaming
in time and time keeps going audio could
keep going for as long as you want so if
you write your code such the audio is a
stream your code will be more resistant
to bugs and will probably not crash in
production or at least not as often
other common problem with audio and
python here let's go back to the example
we had with Distortion that really cool
guitar example
so here's the code that we had before
I'm not going to type it all out again
but we read in our entire audio file and
then we do math.tanh at the bottom here
now I said I wasn't going to get into
what tan H is and I'm not it's a
mathematical function but We're looping
over every single sample here in Python
and this is fairly fast or at least it's
fast enough
if I run this on my laptop it takes
about eight seconds per minute of audio
to run this code so that's a good way
you can measure audio code is you can
take how long it took to run and divide
that by the amount of audio that you
processed through that code and here we
find out that this code runs in what's
called about 7.5 times real time so 7.5
times faster than it would be to just
play back the audio itself
however that still seems a little bit
slow if I have to run this on a minute
of audio I have to wait eight seconds
and I'm very impatient so is there a way
to do this any faster well luckily
python has a lot of libraries and a very
rich ecosystem so I found that you can
use numpy the numerical computation
library to do this exact same operation
instead of doing math.10h there which
only takes in a single sample at a time
we could do numpy.10h which takes in an
entire array at a time and then
processes that through the same function
the results are exactly the same in fact
byte for byte they're identical the
sample values are perfect
but this code at the bottom runs a
little bit faster and uh when I say a
little bit faster I mean it takes only
about 23 milliseconds per minute of
audio
that's a great gasp I'm glad that
happened
uh yeah 23 milliseconds per minute of
audio so that's a little bit faster than
the old code was in fact if we do a bit
of math here and divide these two
it's about 338 times faster to use a
library here instead of manually
iterating over the samples
in our case we use numpy and numpy made
this 338 times faster but you could use
pedalboard or you could use really any
other library that optimizes this away
and uh the last thing I want to talk
about here is really that for audio
pure python is slow I'm not offending
anybody with this statement but pure
python iterating through samples and
doing direct math can be very very slow
compared to Native optimized uh C code
essentially
so if you can use third-party libraries
instead
okay and that brings me to my final
section here which is talking about
audio effects in pedalboard so we've
talked about how to do some of these
effects ourselves and how to make this
sound really good in pure python but
what if we use this cool library that
I've been talking about to do some of
these effects for us
so I'm just going to jump directly into
the code here just like we had before
we're going to read in an audio file and
even though I just told you not to read
in the whole file at once I'm going to
do it here because otherwise it wouldn't
fit on the slide
and I'm going to use pedalboard to
import some audio effects so I'm going
to import an effect here called Reverb
so I'll do from pedalboard import Reverb
and then we'll create an instance of
this Reverb effect we can do that with
Reverb equals capital r Reverb and set
the room size to certain amounts so room
size equals 0.75 whatever that number is
it's just between 0 and 1. I don't think
there's actually a unit on that but it's
good enough
then we can take our input signal here
and pass it through our Reverb plug-in
so affected equals Reverb pass in the
audio and pass in the sample rate and
all of a sudden we've applied an effect
to the audio and it now sounds different
but you don't have to trust me on that
you can actually listen to it so let's
listen to cool guitar wave before and
after once again
and now with the Reverb applied
so musically that's the same but you can
tell that something's changed about that
it sounds like it was played back in a
large room or kind of a bit more boomy a
bit bit bigger and that's a common
effect that musicians will apply to
their audio
so let's keep going there let's get rid
of the Reverb example there and let's
chain multiple effects together so
instead of just applying one effect
let's make an entire pedal board that
contains multiple effects so here we'll
do board equals pedalboard which is
really just a list or a container for
multiple effects and let's add a
distortion effect first followed by a
delay effect
followed by some Reverb on the end now
this is actually very similar to what we
did before in pure python but now we're
just chaining these plugins into an
object that's much easier to deal with
then just like before we'll take our
audio signal and we'll pass it into the
board so we'll do affected equals Board
of audio and f.sample rate and again we
have a before and after comparison here
it's not the same sample this one's a
little bit more tuned for the effects
that we have here but here's the before
[Music]
and then when we put this through some
Distortion delay and Reverb
[Music]
[Applause]
it sounds very different in fact it
sounds kind of musically interesting as
well it's not just affecting the tone of
the sound but it's changing the musical
content too
okay I've talked about some guitar
examples and stuff like that what about
other use cases what if you're not using
pedalboard with music or you're not
affecting your music here what if you
have a podcast that you want to process
so let's read in a podcast voice sample
here we can make a pedalboard that works
on podcasts just like the guitar pedal
boards we've already done here
so let's add a noise gate to get rid of
some background noise let's add a
compressor to make quieter parts of the
sound sound louder let's add a low shelf
filter which is really a kind of
equalizer or EQ and then we'll add some
gain on the end to make the entire thing
a little bit louder
now with these four effects in series
we'll take a voice that's kind of not
really radio ready and turn that into a
voice that sounds much more professional
uh voice basically so we'll pass the
audio in here and then again I'll give
you a before and after and uh apologies
it's going to be my voice which you've
heard already throughout this talk but
yeah here it is
welcome back to the podcast podcast
where I uh talk about podcasts
so that's me recording my really cool
podcast and then once it's gone through
this pedal word here
welcome back to the podcast podcast
where I talk about podcasts much more
full much more boomy arguably but really
sounds more Radio Ready compared to what
I've got there
and then my last example here in my last
two minutes are how you can use
pedalboard to load other plugins as well
I've showed you a bunch of effects
reverbs distortions things like that but
if anybody in this room produces digital
music or uses a computer to produce
music you've probably heard of plugins
or audio plugins vsts audio units and
things like that and pedalboard lets you
take all of those and put those directly
in your code and call those from python
so again let's read in a guitar sample
here
and read in the entire audio file into
an array then let's load a third-party
plugin so I'm going to do plugin equals
load plugin and I'll pass a path to a
VST here so chowcenter.vst3 whoops
that's going too fast
God damn it okay uh we'll load a
third-party plug-in here and that
third-party plugin will have code in it
that we didn't write and in fact it's
not even written in Python so it's code
that you might have downloaded on the
Internet or purchased from somewhere
else because vsts are things that you
can buy anywhere
so we'll load that plugin and then we'll
also do plugin dot show editor editor or
show editor here will actually open up
the plugins UI and directly in Python
you can play with buttons and change the
sliders and do all the sorts of stuff
you might do in your digital audio
Workstation
then just like before we can run audio
through it we'll do print plugin.gain to
change certain parameters we'll set plug
and gain to 1.0 for maximum Rock
and then audio goes through and here's
the before and after one last time
[Music]
and afterwards
and we couldn't have written that in
Python we're just going to use someone
else's code for it and it sounds pretty
good
so with that I'm out of time if you're
interested in using pedalboard you can
find it on GitHub at github.com Spotify
pedalboard or just Pi Pi uh it's it's
available on Pi Pi there pip install
pedalboard thanks so much for listening
uh find me in the hallway for any
questions you might have or for cool
stickers of the nice pedalboard logo
we've got there thanks for